prends du R voilà tu vas chercher
quelqu'un là devant tu as plus de
vitesse parce que tu bouges plus vite
devant les athlètes sont fatigués on y
va on y va on y va on y va on y va c'est
très bien ok j'ai toujours travaillé
travaillé travaillé je sais que le
travail va payer parce que parce que ça
marche comme
[Musique]
ça il me disait que j'allais jamais
pouvoir marcher jamais pouvoir faire
quoi que ce soit avec mon handicap et
cetera ça a été un peu compliqué mais
moi je pense que déjà le goû de
challenge mon plus basage si je suis
bien aujourd'hui c'est aussi grâce à
vous mon équipe professionnelle et c'est
vrai que quand je le disf je trouve même
pas qu'on est une équipe mais une
famille les couleurs bleu blanc rouge
sur Alex c'est une grande fierté
vraiment l'impression d'être avec elle
sur la ligne du stress c'est vraiment un
moment intense je m'étais toujours dit
que j'allais monter sur la plus haute
marche d'un podium
paralympique j'ai même pas de je suis
déjà ému alorsis pas
encore
[Musique]
allez allez enc un peu super c'est bien
d'avoir des athlètes comme ça qui font
travailler je m'appelle Alexandra
noucher j'ai 25 ans je suis paraathlète
j'ai une anomalie congénitale ce qui
veut dire que pour me déplacer
convenablement au quotidien je dois
mettre une prothèse et être àareill j'ai
fait l'annotation pendant un peu plus de
12 ans et j'avais arrêté l'annotation en
2016 j'ai les temps de sélection pour
les jeux de Rio mais malheureusement à
cause d'un système de cotage je n'ai pu
y participer donc ça plus l'accumulation
de pas mal de choses ont fait que je me
suis arrêté complètement je voulais plus
entendre parler de sport et encore moins
de natation et après j'ai repris le
sport en 2018 j'ai intégré une structure
sportive donc le Centre Fédéral handis
sport qui lui proposait plusieurs
disciplines telles que l'athlétisme et
en fait en voyant la team athlet
s'entraîner rigoler prendre du plaisir
pendant l'entraînement bah ça m'a
vraiment poussé à tester donc j'ai testé
une fois deux fois trois fois et puis
bah mon cœur apprenché vraiment pour
l'athlétisme prends du temps entre les
Gets prends du temps Alex en faire ok
d'accord tu veux faire des groupes de TR
ok Alex c'est une passionnée quoi elle
est à fond dans tout ce qu'elle fait
c'est même très agréable c'est c'est une
athlète qu'il faut qu'il faut freiner
même parce que elle a tellement
d'envie c'est pas la que je dois faire
en parallèle du sport je suis chargée de
communication chez EDF donc dans la
direction commerce nord-ouest et puis
j'ai une CIP donc une CP c'est un
contrat insertion professionnelle me
permettant de pouvoir concilier bah mon
projet sportif et mon projet
professionnel et du coup ça ça me permet
de déjà mieux appréhender ma ma retraite
sportive même si elle n'est pas demain
loin de
[Musique]
là là on se rend à l' donc on fait par
une l'Ille pour que je puiss aller
travailler rejoindre mon équipe et puis
par la suite bah je reviens sur Paris
pour pouvoir mentraîner là on a pris le
train de 6h52 à la gare du Nord
habituellement ça va mais là c'est vrai
que ce matin ça pite quand même
aujourd'hui vu que je retrouve ma team
je vais leur ramener le petit
déjeuner ça ça fait partie de plaisir du
matin du
soleil ça y est j'ai récupéré le petit
déjeuner donc là je me rends sur site
pour aller retrouver ma petit courm le
matin ça fait toujours plaisir Alex nous
AG après Alex elle ramène toujours des
petits pains mais elle elle en mange
pasce faire gaffe ouais à sa ligne donc
en fait mange pour moi al pour l'équipe
ce qui est ce qui est chouette c'est que
en fait on on la suit quoi on est on est
ses fans numéro 1 c'estes supporters
numéro 1 donc là les championnats du
monde on a pu aller la voir et du coup
c'était une vraie découverte parce que
c'est pas du tout la même chose que
d'attendre qu'elle nous envoie son SMS
pour nous dire si oui ou non elle est
qualifier et d'être là et de vivre ça
avec elle donc c'était c'était beaucoup
d'émotion et en même temps ça nous a
beaucoup soudé ben oui je vous ai vu ig
avec des rigolé en plus oh elle a
rigolé est tellement fort a dit je sais
pas si c'est bien elle nous a vu du coup
je sais pas peut-être on l'a déconcentré
du tout les couleurs bleu blanc rouge
sur Alex voilà c'est c'est une grande
fierté puis elle nous donne une leçon de
de vie elle s'en rend pas compte mais
c'est une leçon de vie Alexandra c'est
pas un cas isolé chez EDF en fait on a
mis en place plusieurs dispositifs elle
a du temps pour ses entraînements elle
peut faire du télétravail bien entendu
on a adapte au besoins c'est c'est
vraiment de la souplesse ça nous demande
une agilité mais mais c'est c'est du cas
par cas ça dépend des ça dépend des
sportifs et puis bien sûr des missions
adaptées si je suis bien aujourd'hui
c'est aussi par rapport enfin c'est
aussi grâce à vous mon équipe
professionnelle et et puis voilà et
c'est vrai que quand je le dis enfin je
trouve même pas qu'on est une équipe
mais une famille quand je regarde notre
team c'est vrai et je le pense vraiment
je prense vraiment si c'était pas le cas
je vous l'aurais dit
aussi ce qui me fait plaisir c'est c'est
vraiment de voir que bah mes collègues
mon entreprise tout simplement est
mobilisé derrière moi lors des
compétitions au début j'ai j'ai pensé
que ça allait être une pression parce
que je me disais bon ils m'ont jamais vu
courir ils m'ont jamais vu lancer ça
pouvait me procurer un stress mais au
final non c'était c'était réellement une
fierté de pouvoir représenter non
seulement mon entreprise mes proches et
la France je trouve ça important de
garder un bon équilibre entre la vie
professionnelle et la vie sportive en
tout cas moi c'est ce qui me stimule au
quotidien et ça me fait vraiment du bien
il y a beaucoup de sportifs qui du coup
sont obligés de mettre un des projets de
côté parce que ils ont pas forcément le
temps et pour le coup bah moi
franchement j'ai de la chance à ce
niveaau-là et j'en suis très très très
reconnaissante on n'est pas du tout
rémunéré par notre sport et donc du coup
pour pouvoir bah pratiquer ça dans de
très très bonnes conditions parce qu'on
a des besoins matériels qui sont assez
onéreux je cours avec une lame en
carbone une lame en carbone c'est assez
onéreux il faut la conception de la
prothèse et cetera et les c'est pas
donné c'est vraiment pas donné donc du
coup bah déjà avoir des sponsors à ce
niveau-l c'est c'est très important mais
aussi bah pour pouvoir tout simplement
ne manquer de rien dans notre
[Musique]
pratique 43
M4 est Chion mondeion parmi
de
[Musique]
allezz termin ça allit bien parfois Alex
quand tu es cette tête là tu tu sens qu'
y a un petit un petit truc de
frustration mais non donc c'est bien
zéro frustration franchement les
sensations elles sont bonnes ça fait
plaisir parce que bah voilà ça monque
les SCI d'entraînement
pay vite vite vite vite bouche çaou çaou
çaouge ça vousou j'entends un peu je
pense que ma force c'est déjà ma ma
persévérance et en plus de ça bah de par
ma morphologie je me qualifie comme une
personne qui est plutôt puissante dans
le sens où bah j'ai une musculature qui
n'est pas forcément commune à toutes les
femmes et pour le coup je pense que ça
peut être une force donc ça c'est très
positif faut que tu gardes ça j'ai
toujours travailler travailler
travailler je sais que le travail va
payer parce que parce que ça marche
comme ça il me disait que j'allais
jamais pouvoir marcher j'allais jamais
pouvoir faire quoi que ce soit avec mon
handicap et ETA mais moi je pense que
j'avais déjà le goût de challenge mon
plus basage oh si j'arrive à
atindre déjà ma finale ce sera déjà une
belle victoire parce que parce que c'est
quand même les jeux après si je fais un
podium forcément il y a les larmes qui
vont couler si c'est un podium et que je
suis sur la enfin la plus haute marche
donc sur un sur une médaille d'or bah
alors
là je vais beaucoup
pleurer ça fait depuis que je fais de la
natation que je vise ça
et ça serait magique j'ai même pas de B
déj là je suis déjà ému alors que je
sais pas encore mais non franchement ça
serait énorme allez Alex allez
[Musique]
alle je pense que au jeu de Paris bah
voilà on va toucher encore plus de monde
et ça ça va faire plaisir parce que ça
va aussi ouvrir les porte à à des
personnes qui sont peut-être en
situation de handicap mais qui n'usent
pas forcément à enfin tester tout
simplement le parasport et leur tout
simplement leur ouvrir les portes et et
leur permettre de pouvoir découvrir
davantage ce beau monde qui est paraisse
[Musique]
pas